About a year ago, I did the saliva test, the cheek swab test, or the clinic, the results
indicated that the drivers of my cancer are histamine, dairy, and toxins.
Will I need to eat low histamine and avoid dairy the rest of my life?
Well, I don't remember what your histamine genes are, but if you don't have a lot of defects
at your histamine genes, and we didn't point that out in your genetic testing, then the
answer to that is no, you will not have to eat low histamine, you know, a low histamine
diet the rest of your life, if you're in a full remission.
So if the person's in full remission of their cancer, and dairy and histamine were drivers
of their cancer, so let's say you have no genetic issues with histamine, then I'd say
going back on some histamine pooled slowly and carefully would be fine.
Going back and eating some good organic dairy, especially butter would be just fine.
If you have a lot of genetic issues with histamine, that's going to be just an issue forever.
Those genetic issues are never going to go away.
You should be eating a lot of dairy, no one can have cancer or not.
Personally I don't drink any milk, I eat butter, but I do eat some cheese, but is there
another test to determine which toxins are driving the cancer?
Well if your cancer is in remission, it may not, definitely may show with the Cheekswab test.
Is there other tests to determine what toxins you have that could be an issue of your cancer?
Yes, there's lots of other tests.
So, if you went to the lab store, so there's some good tests that I would say would be beneficial
to look at if you're looking at specific toxins, and here's two of them.
So the GPL test looks for glyphosate, the mycotox test looks for mycotoxins, mycotoxins
are for mold, those are two things that you could look at.
This GPL test is underutilized for sure, so glyphosates are a huge issue at a huge problem
at our environment.
So there's lots of different ways that you can measure these things by running these different
tests.
There is a, so I'm just looking at real quick through the oxic tests that you could run.
There is a metal's hair test that you could do, that gives you a picture of toxic metals
in, by doing a hair analysis test, but it's so as far as toxins go, then there are some
directs and petals, I think it's the array 12, no, not the array 12, that will measure if
you have antibodies to toxins, so that's a whole other picture.
So if I have toxins in my body, it's the array 11.
So the Cyrex array 11 measures antibodies to different toxins and biomarkers, which is
a whole other ball of wax if people have serious illness that they have been a lot of different
places and can't get better, some of these functional medicine tests is what's measured
in the array 11 can be really beneficial because you can actually end up developing antibodies
to different toxins.
Now, you have these antibodies and every time you're exposed to these things, now you fire
a reaction to those.
If you also have self antibodies, we need antibodies to self tissue, like person-witted Hashimoto's,
like most of you probably do because autoimmune disease is so rampant and I wrote a note about
in my book, you know, when it first came out in 2010 that I think cancer has an autoimmune
component with every single person, so if you really want to dig deeper in tests, so
a lot of people, you know, they come to me and they just, you know, they're having serious
issues with cancer, they just want to get better, once they get into the remission, they don't
want to go any farther.
And then there's some people like possibly the person who asked this question, I actually
have the wrong question here, but the person that asked this question, want to dig a little
deeper and find out some other things that can be going on, they might be in full remission,
but I want to dig deeper and figure out some other things.
If you want to find out if you have antibodies to self tissue, the best test I think is the
CyRex array 5.
So that test is measures a good array of self antibodies, self tissue antibodies and really
gives you an idea if you have what other things that you have going on.
If you have a lot of brain fog, brain issues, I can't figure out why I can't dig straight
on concern about Alzheimer's, then the array 14 and the array 7X are really good.
This is the array 5 and on the biomarkers that a test support, these are antibodies to all
these different self tissues that are so important and these are hidden in a lot of people.
The array 14 gives you the APO antibodies, it really looks at the brain antibodies as far
as Alzheimer's disease go, so you can really measure whether I have to make some drastic
lifestyle changes so that I could push Alzheimer's, Alzheimer's and dementia diseases as far
out into the future as possible.
The array 7 and array 7X is a little more expanded, is antibodies to neural tissues, so different
neurons, microglial cells, astrocytes, and other glial cells, and myelin cheese cells and things
like that, because that's a huge issue with people, especially after doing chemo.
It's one of the issues that they have with, quote unquote, chemo-brain is they actually
have antibodies to their own tissue or they have microglial primate, which either one causes
inflammation of the brain, and that's a lower than half lecture right there.
If you want to go look more about that, go to my video on issues that could happen with
brain inflammation.
I think if you go to the blog and you search rated inflammation, you can find out more information
about that.